[Música]
en estos momentos de tanta contemplación
y de tanto aislamiento posiblemente
estamos angustiados pensando cómo vamos
a salir de este asunto cómo vamos a
salir de este enredo
y tal vez para empezar a pensar en esto
lo más importante es entender qué
significa tener éxito
qué significa salir de este empleado y
para mí significa tres cosas para
empezar de disciplina y significa que
logremos mantener el control de la
epidemia porque lo que puede ocurrir
médicamente cambia mucho dependiendo de
qué hacemos segundo que sepamos ser
solidarios que sepamos que hay gente que
en este momento está sufriendo más que
los demás que le está pasando peor que
eso les golpea más y como sociedad
tenemos que entender que a los demás nos
toca ayudarlos a ellos a sobrellevar de
mejor manera este golpe y lo tercero es
que tenemos que crear las bases para
volver a crecer porque este no sólo es
un problema de salud también es un
problema económico también es un
problema social
estamos llevándonos un golpe enorme en
esos sentidos y es importante desde el
control de la epidemia y después de que
esta pesadilla termine haber sentado las
bases para que la sociedad no se golpee
tanto y para que volvamos a crecer como
economía
y es que esta enfermedad aparece hecha
para hacer daño
tiene características que hacen que su
impacto social y económico sea todavía
más fuerte para empezar es una
enfermedad que nos obliga aislarnos es
una enfermedad que nos obliga a
distanciarnos de la gente y esto tiene
costos por todo lado hay muchas
actividades productivas muchas formas de
generar ingresos que simplemente no
funcionan si estamos ayudados de los
demás que no podemos trabajar si no
estamos pegados con los demás estar
aislados tiene más costos adicionales
hasta psicológicos pero además de un
costo para la gente que requiere de
atención especial y entonces una
enfermedad que nos obliga el darnos es
una enfermedad que de por sí nos va a
pegar muy duro tenemos que ayudarnos
pero no va a ser gratis y no va a ser
fácil es una enfermedad en la cual los
sanos pueden transferir la gente que
aparentemente no tiene síntomas o gente
que tiene síntomas tan ligeros que no
sabemos que esto es lo que tiene igual
podrían ser los transmisores de este
virus porque podrían estar infectados y
por lo tanto no basta con aislar a los
que sabemos que están enfermos tenemos
que ayudarnos todos y eso hace
para la sociedad todavía mayor y además
es una enfermedad en la cual algunas
personas desgraciadamente están en
riesgo de muerte y requieren cuidados
muy intensivos y es un problema porque
significa que como la capacidad de la
sociedad de prestar esos cuidados no es
infinita como hay límites en cuánta
gente puede estar recibiendo este tipo
de cuidados simultáneamente no podemos
como con otras enfermedades simplemente
pensar pues nos enfermamos poco a poco y
se curarán la mayoría y se morirán
algunos y no queda otra que hacer no
podemos confiar en la inmunidad de
rebaño porque aún si nos terminamos
enfermando todos la cantidad de nosotros
que van a faltar si nos enfermamos poco
a poco o si nos enfermamos todos a la
vez son muy diferentes y por lo tanto lo
prudente que hacer en términos de salud
lo que hay que hacer tiene un costo
económico y tiene un costo social
inevitables
ahora afortunadamente por otro lado hay
países de donde salen lecciones que han
tenido éxito igual que hay pensadores y
científicos que de cuyos análisis sale
ideas que sabemos que pueden tener éxito
no estamos perdidos aprendamos de esas
cosas como ya hemos visto la cantidad de
enfermos en algunos países como corea
del sur o como china baja cada día en
vez de subir como ya hemos visto en
algunas sociedades no ha sido necesario
cerrar todo porque las cosas
inteligentemente éste llevan a mejores
resultados que hicieron esos países que
tuvieron éxito y que dicen esos
pensadores que nos están dando ideas de
cómo reaccionar acá pero lo primero que
nos dicen es lo mismo que nos hemos
dicho hasta la saciedad pero que hay que
hacerlo aislamiento son sociedades que
se aislaron del mundo controlando mucho
quienes entran quienes salen y tratando
de evitar que la entrada y salida
necesaria de algunas personas por
ejemplo los que tienen que ver con la
carga se convierta en un riesgo de
contagio mayor
aislándonos entre regiones
la gente no se mueva de un lugar del
país al otro en números tan grandes
porque así podrían estar llevando la
enfermedad de un lugar donde está
infectado a un lugar donde todavía no ha
llegado y también ayudándonos unos a los
otros distanciamiento social prácticas
de higiene prácticas de cuidado entre
nosotros para que no tengamos tanta
cercanía que pueda incluir en algunos
momentos que simplemente nos manden para
la casa
también algunos países han tenido mucho
éxito simplemente generando tantas
pruebas de laboratorio tantos peces para
saber no sólo así los que parecen tener
síntomas están contagiadas sino para
saber a dónde más han del contagio que a
partir de ahí se puede utilizar la
analítica de datos para saber a dónde
concentrar los esfuerzos haciendo
cuarentenas inteligentes como las
cápitas de una cebolla
en el centro hasta una persona que ya
sabemos que está enferma que sabemos que
está infectada obviamente esa persona se
cuarentena pero también sabemos que esa
persona ha tenido contacto con otros y
eso también se cuarentena porque podría
ser un fuego una fuente de infección y
vamos identificando en la tercera cápita
de la cebolla con quienes tuvieron
contacto esos tal vez no para
contenerlos pero sí para mantenerlos en
observación y vamos generando la
información de la cuarta capa de la
cebolla y cada vez que alguien adentro
en las capas de adén nos enferma muestra
síntomas ahora ya sabemos que está
contagiado empezamos a ir dar las capas
exteriores y eso nos permite dirigirnos
a las personas que realmente están
enfermas
y dirigirnos también a aislar con mucho
cuidado a las personas que están en
mayor riesgo porque las personas que
tienen cierta edad ciertas
preexistencias médicas o ciertos hábitos
complicados están mucho más riesgo de
fallecer por esta enfermedad que el
resto de la población en algunos países
no ha hecho falta que el gobierno ordene
las cosas en suecia por ejemplo el
distanciamiento social voluntario
funcionó el gobierno dijo mejor todo el
mundo es a distancia y la gente se
distanció tanto que la epidemia empezó a
estar bajo control en alemania -la en
parte porque se hicieron muchísimas
pruebas en salud se ha hecho un uso muy
inteligente de los datos han logrado que
teniendo los mismos enfermos que sus
vecinos el número de fallecimientos sea
una mentira aparte tengan sus otros
países en dinamarca cuando llegó el
momento de hacer un cierre estratégico
profundo de la sociedad se supieron
poner de acuerdo
empresas trabajadores y gobiernos para
minimizar
el costo de ese cierre y para que
aquellos más afectados pudieran ser
apoyados solidariamente por los demás y
este último punto me parece
particularmente relevante porque está
llegando creo yo y este es el principal
mensaje que estoy trayendo hoy está
llegando el momento de un aislamiento
temporal profundo para reducir el número
de contagios y para reducirlo y para
generar los datos que nos permitan
echarle a esto con bisturí y no con
martillo porque una vez que bajemos el
número de contagiados que sepamos
quiénes son y que sepamos dónde está el
contagio los culturales pueden ser mucho
más teledirigidos en el caso de costa
rica creo que ese momento está llegando
porque debemos aprovechar la semana
santa un cierre estratégico un momento
en el cual todo el mundo está en
cuarentena y solo está abierto a lo
esencial ojalá por unos 14 días un
poquito más
un ciclo de contagio completo nos
permite hacer eso nos permite enfrentar
a la enfermedad con una nueva realidad y
empezar a aflojar incluso ciertos
controles y empezar a volver a crecer en
un periodo como esos el costo económico
de parar es muy grande por el país
sierra de por sí por semana santa
muchísimas cosas baja su intensidad
producción o dejan de producir
completamente porque estamos en los días
santos lo que quiere decir que esos 14 o
16 días con los fines de semana esos 16
días de cierre profundo están a mitad de
precio en semana santa pues está la
mitad porque la mitad de septiembre de
por si vamos a tener por supuesto que un
cierre de ese tipo las cosas esenciales
siguen funcionando todo lo que tiene que
ver con producir nos llevarnos y
vendernos comida todo lo que tiene que
ver con la salud con las armas con la
farmacia y las medicinas y los
implementos médicos con la seguridad con
el cuidado de los más necesitados con
los servicios básicos esos señores van a
tener que seguir trabajando porque si no
los demás no somos viables
pero lo demás según cierre está técnico
profundo a la casa aislarse aprovechando
ese mismo rápido ese mismo rato para
hacer pruebas de laboratorio masivamente
que nos permitan tener los datos para
entrarle a esto con más inteligencia y
si un cierre profundo como éste ojalá
gobierno anunció ya medidas para semana
santa
ojalá que la semana santa dure dos ojalá
que aprovechemos a esta oportunidad un
cierre profundo de este tipo tiene un
costo no hay duda pero a mí me parece
que ese costo el menor en términos de
vidas en términos de empleos en términos
de producción en términos de costo
social
ese costo es menor que seguir una
trayectoria actual en que los controles
no son máximos pero están a donde están
ya nos afectan y van subiendo por meses
y meses o puede ser mucho peor así que
aprovechemos la semana santa para hacer
un cierre profundo que nos permita
entrar al siguiente capítulo de esta
película porque el camino que nos falta
todavía es más o menos largo
estamos ahora en una fase de contagio el
número de casos crece afortunadamente en
costa rica la curva se ha frenado un
poquito en otros países crece a una
velocidad muy preocupante y no hacer
hasta que hagamos cosas como ese cierre
estratégico u otras medidas parecidas
que vamos a tener control sobre la
epidemia no va a acabar van a haber van
a seguir habiendo enfermos la enfermedad
va a seguir estando ahí pero por lo
menos ya no vamos ya no vamos sin
goleado vamos a ir empatados con ellos y
ahí empieza un proceso que algunos
expertos habrán llamado el baile porque
bailamos con la enfermedad cuando la
logramos controlar un poco baja la
intensidad podemos bajar controles eso
me permite volver a nuestra vida un
poquito más normal a producir un poquito
más a salvar un poquito más de empleos
cuando eso sucede y bajamos los
controles a veces de enfermedad vuelve a
subir y los tenemos que subir con ella y
tenemos que bailar con ella un rato
hasta que haya y ahora esto puede durar
unos meses puede dar un año a traer una
vacuna hasta que hay una cura y a partir
de la vacuna y la cura es que llegamos a
una nueva
normalidad
como se administra ese baile bueno con
controles ojalá cada vez más selectivo y
más teledirigidos utilizando los datos y
las multitud de pruebas para saber dónde
está el problema para poder realizar
esto con un bisturí y no con un martillo
siempre sin tener actividades masivas de
puertas desgraciadamente yo le estadio
saprissa no volveré por un rato hay
cierto tipo de actividad que no puede
ocurrir mientras no tengamos cura o
buena en ese rato tenemos que ser muy
cuidadosos para apoyar solidariamente a
las personas que entren en dificultades
que van a ser muchos porque hay mucha
gente que en estas coyunturas no les no
les es fácil funcionar es muy importante
que aseguremos la estabilidad financiera
y macroeconómica del país y que
aseguremos que tanto el gobierno como el
sistema financiero tienen liquidez es
muy importante que hagamos cambios para
ser más eficientes más productivos y más
competitivos justo en esta coyuntura que
nos llevemos a línea muchas cosas que
siempre han sido en papel que aprendamos
a tener trabajar que aprendamos a
funcionar en esta nueva realidad y ser
más productivos en nuestra realidad es
importante que identifiquemos los
sectores que van a verse más afectados
como el turismo y que le demos apoyo a
esos sectores para que esas empresas y
los empleos sobrevivan pero que dos
apoyos sean condicionados
la sociedad te ayuda si vos ayudas a tus
trabajadores la sociedad te ayuda si vos
ayudas a tu comunidad y es muy
importante que nos aseguremos durante el
baile que la logística sigue funcionando
que las cosas se pueden mover adentro
del país y pueden entrar y salir del
país porque si no entramos en problemas
de otro tipo que son mucho más profundos
mientras tanto esperamos la vacuna y
esperamos la cura preparándonos para una
nueva normalidad porque cuando escampe
las varas son distintas cuando escampe
vamos a arrancar muy endeudados cuando
escampe vamos a haber perdido muchas
empresas también tristemente muchas
personas vamos haber perdido mucha
empresa algunos sectores entero durán a
estar afectados pues cuando escampe
vamos a estar en una organización muy
profunda pero vamos a haber aprendido a
utilizar tecnologías que ya teníamos y
no utilizábamos y que nos vimos
obligados a utilizar ahora vamos a haber
emprendido nuevos hábitos y nuevas
habilidades que ojalá se queden con
nosotros y sobre todo ojalá
adquiramos en esta experiencia valores
que nos que nos llevemos con nosotros
así que si le ponemos salimos de este
alrededor pero hay que ponerle de todo
hay que poner la cabeza no solo viendo
las ideas de otros que han funcionado
para aplicarlas sino también inventando
nuestras propias soluciones hay que
poner el corazón acordándonos que hay
gente muy fregada en este momento que
particularmente necesita nuestro apoyo y
que particularmente necesita nuestra
ayuda y hay que ponerle otras cosas
porque hay a este momento la cl está en
la cancha en este momento tenemos héroes
peleando contra la enfermedad en el
frente de batalla y no sólo son los
médicos de los enfermeros también la
gente que producen comida pero la
seguridad
entonces en nombre de esos este es el
momento de pensar colectivamente de
pensar en los de verdad más afectados
este no es el momento de jalar harina
para nuestro costal y este no es el
momento para dividirlos está el momento
de ponerle juntos para ganar este
partido y yo creo yo sé que podemos
hacer
[Música]